hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr seht bereits im Titel
eingeblendet wir schauen uns heute die
ersten Videos von deutschen Youtubern an
in Form von Sandra heute ja ähm das wird
sehr Grinch glaube ich kann sein dass
ich später irgendwann verschwinde weil
ich jetzt zu viel grinscher ich finde
sogar grindriger wenn wir jetzt mein
aktuelles Video gucken als wenn man
altes Video gucken ja wir starten
erstmal mit dem Content den Sand als
letztes hochgeladen hat damit ihr
überhaupt sehen was sie überhaupt zu
machen
[Musik]
heute ganz spontan Moment hoch hier
wow
Eiffelturm Tower
Leute wir sind jetzt
[Gelächter]
guck mal super Moment ich komme jetzt
von der anderen Seite
vom Eiffelturm ich kann nichts
sagen
also das sieht Sandra aktuell so auf
Youtube hoch ne wenn ihr bei ihr
vorbeischauen wollt das ist ihr Name
gerne abonnieren auch sag mal dein
Instagram Laser Luca könnt ihr auch
gerne vorbeischauen wir schauen uns
jetzt auf jeden Fall Sandra das erste
Video an ich finde deine Thumbnails echt
super die du hier damals hochgeladen
hast
ich drehe das ganze noch mal
was wolltest du denn machen
Salto oder was kann ich weiß es selber
nicht das ist so unangenehmung ganz
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Blog
von mir am Samstag
stellt euch guten Tag
nein wir machen nicht
Alter guck mal deine alte Wohnung noch
krass ne
ich nehme euch heute mit in den Tag what
I do today
ich muss das allererstes mit dem Hund
raus da muss ich mein Kleiderschrank
aufräumen und essen essen dann muss ich
mich heute noch Beauty fertig machen
weil ich dir heute den Klo mit ganz
vielen harten weiß das hat sich
natürlich nicht verändert mein Leben
sieht genauso noch aus wie jetzt einfach
ganz viel Wäsche machen und abends
fertig machen
[Musik]
eine Sache die ihr bei uns in der
Familie alle gleich haben wir werden
immer mit Essen angelockt okay
das ganze Video geht auch nur eineinhalb
Minuten einfach
[Musik]
hey Leute und ganz herzlich willkommen
zu einem
neuen Vlog bei mir auf dem Channel
ich mache heute eine Challenge denn ich
werde mich gleich eine Stunde lang in
diesem Gerät hier verstecken ich habe
mir sogar eine Lidl Tüte drin wow
bearbeitet
auf diese Idee gekommen eine Stunde im
Kleiderschrank keine Ahnung Digger keine
Ahnung was in meinem gehen immer selber
nicht
ab und zu frag ich mich Alter was ist
das ich besitze ein paar mehrere Hosen
in die passe ich leider seit einem
ganzen Jahr nicht mehr rein
wie du weiter mit dem Schiff guckt euch
mal dieses Kleid an ja junge wer hat die
verarscht Alter was ist das
Besondere was ist das für ein Video
keine Ahnung ich bin mal weiter ich
sitze glaube ich mit Katharina drin
mittlerweile habe ich dann auch schon
wieder oha bekommen und ist jetzt mal
los
es schmeckt doch besser als gedacht man
ähm ja was wollte als nächstes sehen was
den Kleiderschrank mache schreibt einen
Kommentare ich bin ja Bruder
Luca das ist meine Nummer löschen ich
frage mich nicht warum ich Single bin es
also ganz ehrlich der musst du einmal ja
Katastrophe ganz herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen Vlog ihr habt es Euch alle
gewünscht
wie ich zu meiner geilen Figur komme
Sport mache ich immer mit Gucci Pulli
Alter 500 €
habe ich immer noch ne
weil wir ja immer alle so Schwitzen beim
Sport habe ich mir zuerst die
Schweißband gekauft dann packe ich immer
hin das verhindert mein Schweiß
[Applaus]
so leute wir beginnen erstmal mit 30
Hampelmänner
[Musik]
Pausen sehen vor allem in Ordnung machen
[Applaus]
so Leute jetzt kommen wir auch schon zu
der allerletzten Übung die Übung der
Übungen weil alle Typen bestehen auf den
Arsch deswegen machen wir jetzt kurz und
so machen wir das richtig ganz wichtig
Knie über Fußspitzen
ey das ist der größte schwarze den ich
je gesehen habe
hallo
klatschen einblenden
[Musik]
starten jetzt mit ähm ich habe übrigens
noch Vorlage Ducati kannst du jetzt
einbinden
schon gesagt packt ihr das Wasser in so
blöd seconds later
ihr müsst einfach und sowas
dieses Video reinziehen was denken die
denn wer ich bin wie siehst du aus keine
Ahnung du kannst jetzt mach mal ganz ans
Ende weil ich habe da glaube ich noch
eine Performance drinne
[Musik]
hey Sandra ich kack ab bitte lösch
deinen Kanal ich
löschen ja wenn es euch gefallen hat
lasst einen Daumen hoch unter Video da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nichts
verpassen besonders kann alles
selbstverständlich und in der
Beschreibung verlinkt wenn euch diese
ganzen Videos noch mal normal anschauen
wollt dann kannst du im Dezember mal ein
bisschen Kohle machen nee ich habe auch
eine Idee für die mein neues Armband ja
habe ich auch das soll zur Leistung von
Gleichgewicht was bringen
ihr wollt könnt ihr meinen Kanal auch
gerne melden
ciao